pour une culture en france qui au sein
du parlement est davantage une culture
législatives donc de débats et
d'empoignades homérique ne prenons que
le texte sur l'ouverture du mariage aux
personnes de même sexe on a eu des
heures et des heures de débat pour
finalement une issue qui était quasiment
connu davance en revanche et c'est là
que peut-être les parlementaires
pourraient réfléchir aujourd'hui mais
comme il aurait pu le faire depuis des
années je pense que il y à un autre rôle
du parlement a développé qui évidemment
ce rôle de contrôle et d'évaluation
le fait que les textes soient
aujourd'hui adoptée par voie
d'ordonnancé
dès lors que ce sont des textes
législatifs lors laisse au contraire
toute latitude pour contrôler ce que
fait le gouvernement est ce que les
objectifs sont atteints et le cas
échéant proposer des réformes
donc c'est aussi peut-être une occasion
de réinventer ou de réfléchir à un
nouvel équilibre des fonctions du
parlement